la derecha celebra en Israel los boca de
urna repitan el mismo resultado del
unísono benjaminyahu tendrá la mayoría
necesaria para formar gobierno Los
Seguidores y candidatos de licut
festejaron la victoria
pero una cosa ya está Clara Nuestro
camino el delicut ha demostrado su
eficacia
les recuerdo que de los 52 escaños que
obtuvimos en las últimas elecciones
estamos ahora a un punto de conseguir
una gran Victoria
las cifras aún no están confirmadas sin
embargo el extrema derechista y tomar
behibir se dirigió a sus fanáticos para
celebrar el legislador es el Aliado
clave de netanyahu para formar la
coalición y su partido está en tercer
lugar el público desea un liderazgo que
proteja la tierra de Israel el público
votó hoy por la identidad judía queremos
hacer una separación total entre
aquellos que son leales al Estado de
Israel y aquellos que socaban nuestro
querido país
en contrapartida el actual Primer
Ministro y Air lapiz mantuvo expectativa
al águilas eh esperaremos pacientemente
los datos finales vine aquí esta noche
para dar las gracias desde el fondo de
mi corazón no tenemos intención de
detenernos todo ciudadano de Israel debe
saber esta noche que continuaremos
luchando para que Israel sea un estado
judío y democrático liberal y
progresista
de certificarse El Triunfo electoral de
netanyahu mal recibido desde la
autoridad nacional Palestina Israel
podría superar el estancamiento político
en el que está Hace cuatro años el país
actualmente mantiene un costo de vida en
alza y relaciones tensas con vecinos
árabes de la región